[Musique]
des lumières de la musique une piste qui
s'illumine bienvenue sur la troisième
étape de l'UCI track Champions League un
événement programmé pour la première
fois au Vélodrome national de 50 ans en
Yvelines et qui réunit les meilleurs
pistes mondiaux avec un objectif en tête
pour les organisateurs casser les codes
l'ADN de lucrat champion 6 c'est
vraiment de fabriquer de l'ontar timment
autour du cyclisme sur Pitt donc des
animations à travers de la nouvelle
technologie on va conserver
exclusivement les formats les plus
impressionnants en matière de sport
toujours autour du cyclisme sur piste et
c'est vraiment voilà pour se démarquer
de ce qui peut se faire d'habitude et de
continuer à développer cette pratique
d'attirer encore plus de monde des
familles comme ce qui se fait en
Angleterre à Berlin d'attirer tout ce
monde-là en France et plus
particulièrement à 50 ans en Yvelines au
total plus de 3000 spectateurs sont
venus voir ce spectacle ce samedi 26
novembre le show il est très bien ils
ont mis de la musique il y a de
l'ambiance avec un jeu de lumière
ça change de l'habitude c'est mieux
comme ça mais je crois qu'ils ont trouvé
le bon principe pour faire vibrer les
spectateurs et faire venir les tous les
tous les passionnés de vélo dans les
Vélodrome le public a pu voir une
victoire de la favorite locale Mathilde
de gros la piste qui s'entraîne dans la
structure c'est imposée face à la
Colombienne Martin Bayona en vitesse
elle termine deuxième sur le Kirin
[Musique]
c'est toujours des superbes émotions en
plus il y avait il y avait beaucoup de
monde donc la main c'est cool ma famille
toujours au même endroit dans les
tribunes non franchement c'est ça fait
que des bons souvenirs pour toute ma vie
quoi Lucie trek Champions League devrait
revenir l'année prochaine pour une
nouvelle édition au plus grand bonheur
des spectateurs
[Musique]